ていた
あードアたり地面全部行きこんにちははじめ社長です里山に帰って対応バブ c 松山
に帰ってきたわけだがる今日は
雪だるまを作りたいと思います眩しいねほんと今更雪だるまを作るというとりあえず
まず雪に触れる機会がすごい久しぶりなので純粋に
スクリターンや増税に雪だるまを作りたいというのもあるんですけどもこの2十三たい
というこの成人ら前になった年において小学校の時呼び雪だるま作ってたんですけども
あの頃は響きだったピンに今日までここもぜんぜん格好で法律の悪い雪だ今の作り方を
していたのかなと思いまして今最強の筋力対抗後せいぜいてを兼ねそろえて今の私は
最強のはもうなんか祝ぐらいみんな
だが引くくらい大きな雪だるまを作れるのかなと思って今回作ってみようと思った所存
でございます
北
明日しぞーか買えるんですよ最後の思い出にさ
で原油りっ
で経由来られます作ろうやっぱり雪って明るいなぁ
行き当たる来て全然見えない画面が開いていうわけでまず雪を触ったことない人のため
に行きだればの簡単な作り方を教えてあげます
会津適当に
明日芸協いいはあの雪の質にもよるんですよな皿の雪だが固まりにくいんですけど
こんなにすごい固まりやすい雪のタイミングですこれはいいぞ
ちょっと小さめが雪玉をつくってこれは後コロコロ転がすだけでどんどん大きくなって
いきます固まり楽しいですおい
転がしていくとわかるかなぁ周り時期金くっついてって明らかに大きくなっていくん
です
4いやもうでもうやばいもうやばいです
やばいもうもうやばいやほんの30秒転がすだけではどうしたんだよ
やばいやばい誕生日を志しただけでこの大きさまで変わり果てます
ああ今筋力はもうあるのでもうちょっと大きくいけるかと思います
回していくよ
朝雪だるま作っています
[音楽]
ん
うん知っています
4日
ぶーぶーとん
ここらへんの地元の高校生がいたんですけどシャベルを貸してくれるみたいでちょっと
シャベルって売ってありますちょっと目でも日が暮れちまうまずで結構でやっぱりここ
らへんまで来てるんですよ
もう一歩でしたうん
[音楽]
増分 a ok
はいこれねアイゼンはなんか下でかいよね素敵なイブであるでかなり大きい方だと思い
ます
入ってだけで雪だるまの人は完成したんですけどもちょっと日が暮れてきて時間が年度
で速攻で頭だけ作っちゃいます
me
[音楽]
ああああああ
ああああああああ
バッハ
car
wh
ok ok を聞き山田ですここから上をもずっと大きくしていきます
[音楽]
怖い
4回か愛と湯気で完成しました女子身長だけでいうとほぼ僕と一緒ですよ
180くらい下級180センチくらいでございますないというわけで一人で作ろうと
思ったんですけど
地元の男の子が手伝ってくれまして物に完成しました
それがとミックさんぽいなというわけで私の作った雪であれば
とくとご堪能あれ
なんということでしょう
ただの雪も
手首の手にかかれば
という間に顎のば人になってしまいました
美しいあご鳥一鶴2つのしょっぱくが特徴的なとってもかわいらしい雪だるまの完成
です
[音楽]
わーっ
me
ああああああ
[音楽]
あっはぁ